Vous pensez avoir vu tous les jeux vidéos les plus bizarres du monde ?
C'est faux !
Alors, aujourd'hui y'a des gens qui vont être contents, d'autres beaucoup moins ! Hein ?
AAaaah la bequille par le siège
Ami(e)s feticheurs des pieds je vous ai refaits !
Ami(e)s podophobes vous êtes dans la merde!
(Pied qui parle)
Allez ! C'est tout pour moi
Ok ! Aujourd'hui on est sur AshiWash
Et vous l'avez deviné on va devoir juste laver un putain de pied
qui menace de péter notre maison si euuuh... on le lave pas
Me demandez pas pourquoi
Je... je sais PAS !
Du coup... ah ok il faut trouver les instruments pour laver ce putain de pied
Okai, Opla ! Ah c'est ça qu'il faut dégager !
Putain, je suis une grosse merde. Je ne me lave jamais les pieds !
Eh mon gars, abuse pas la mouche ! Putain c'est pire que les moustiques en été !
Voila ça dégage. Ca ça dégage aussi !
(bruit de tapette à mouche dans l'air)
Nique.... la république !
Allez s'teplait la mouche
Allez ne me force pas à aller chercher le spray RAID
MERDE !
Ta gueule ! Tu.. tu te tais ! Ta geule le pied !
Tiens, j'te claque l'ongle moi ! Ah c'est déguelasse mon gars... ahh.
Ahhhhhhhhh, OK on a juste une minute pour tuer deux mouches mon gars
Même dans la vraie vie on va plus vite !
OK c'est... une pioche ?!
(rigole)
On va chopper du minerais de cuivre !
ça sert à quoi ?
Ahh c'est pour retirer ça ! Ok, d'accord.
Eh, eh, c'est bien du cuivre mec hein !
Ta gueule...
S'il te plaît..
Eh déjà tu me parles autrement mec t'es un PIED et quand t'es un pied tu te calmes !
Eh mec... !
Mais choppe-le ce putain de cuivre !
J'vais pas rager sur un jeu où tujetubtjue tu te bats contre un pied mec !
Ahhh, voilà !
ça dégage, ça dégage
Ah, j'ai trouvé mec !
YOLO !!!
MAIS OUI !
Voilà la solution mec !
C'est ça qu'on veut.
Voilà, ça c'est fait.
Le problème, c'est qu'il reste des mouches...
Comment on vadzhrgibgdz s'démoucher
Et je sais que vous vous demandez pourquoi vous regardez cette vidéo
Et moi j'vais vous.... Eh, vous croyez que j'me dis quoi ?
Vous croyez que j'me dis pas "Pourquoi je joue à ce jeu...?" ?
HEIN ?
Arrête, mais putai...
J'me fais bloquer par un gros doigt de pied mec...
Si j'avais su un jour que.......
*pied qui parle*
Tu fermes.... tu FERMES tes ORTEILS !
Il est où le truc pour péter les mouches ?
Et c'est quoi ce gros couloir ?
Y'a quoi là, y'a de l'eau ?
... du spray ?
Du spray.... c'est pour quoi ? C'est pour les verrues ?
C'est quoi ça... *désespoir*
Beh t'sais quoi au pire on se cache dans l'armoire, il fera rien du tout le pied !
Là il fait quoi....?
D'accord ! Ok, il a écrasé notre maison...
Que la puissance de la pédicure soit avec nous.
Ouuiiii, on connait ton discours de pied, ça va, ça va
On a l'habitude...
Ok c'est parti bitch !
Hm... BITCH !
Mon gars, là j'vais pas t'mentir on va pas perdre de temps MON GARS
Voilààà ! MEURS !
... MEUUUUUUUUURS !!!
Putain...
J'arrive, bitch !
Voilààà
On perd pas d'temps !
Ain't got time.
Le temps, c'est la santé des pieds.
Voilà, c'est pas ça le proverbe mais on s'en bat les c***lles
ça dégage !
Ok ici y'a un Insécateur euuh un... un sécateur
Putain... je joue trop à Pokémon Go
Ta gueule, ta gueule, ta gueule...
Allez, on coupe tout ça.
Ahhh c'est répugnant mec, c'est tellement répugnant !
Ramène tes doigts de pied
Ahh mec, ces vieux ongles...
Est-ce que vos ongles ont déjà poussé aussi loin ?
Hein, ça vous est déjà arrivé une fois ou pas ?
Moi j'dirai rien sur ce sujet...
Vite les chiottes ! Il nous faut la bombe !
On arrête de parler, on a pas que ça à foutre putain...
C'est bon je l'ai, je l'ai.. ça lague. Je.. J'sais pas pourquoi ça lague
C'pas grave, on y va !
On y va, on y va, on y va, on y va !
On a 1:22 pour finir... ça passe, mec.
Allez go go go go go...OUI...NON !
C'pas grave, j'fais celui-là !
Ok, et de un !
Le 2ème il nous reste une minute, putain on est large... on est laaarge
Et voiii....LÀ !
NON !! Elle est où la pioche ?!
37 secondes mec ? Si, on a le temps, on a le temps...
NOOONNN !!
TA GUEULE ! J'm'énerve contre un pied...
C'est bon, c'est bon y'a plus rien...
NON !
Le spray il est où ?
Oh non c'est la fin...
Mais non ça c'est pas grave, ça on en a tous un p'tit comme ça.... c'est pas gra..
... pas vous ?
Il va écraser notre maison... on est baisés
Où est la bombe ?
Elle devrait être là mec, pourquoi elle n'est pas là ?
Surprise motherfucker !
Moi il est ninckel mon pied hein...
On est plus à ça près, on peut parler de tout maintenant.
Bon les gars on est prêts on va applaudir ce pied, il brillera encore
plus que mon visage après avoir passé dix heures à geeker à Overwatch
Yeaaah, bitch !
Je m'embrasse les doigts après avoir touché un pied...
J'adore !
Bon voilà les gens c'est la fin de cette vidéo
N'hésitez pas à l'aimer si ça vous a écoeuré ou si vous... si vous avez une petite passion secrète pour les pieds
.. et que vous être "féticheurs" des pieds y'a pas de soucis, entre.... c'est pas grave.
Chacun est comme il est, et chacun aime ce qu'il aime.
Voilà, appelez-moi Captain Obvious.
Et franchement, si ça peut vous faire kiffer...
... c'est gratuit.
Allez, merci d'avoir regardé et à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo
Portez-vous bien !
Ouais, je remets ma chaussette, qu'est-ce qu'il se passe ?
On a franchi le cap de la chaussette !
Ciao tout le monde, PEACE !